i was just looking up just going yeah
this is happening from nude scenes on
day two to the jumpsuit with more
character than sandra bullock the lost
city is jam-packed with hilarious
moments on set let's take a look at what
was going on in the jungle
my name is chan today uh this is just
what it is number one sandra bullock
described tatum's booty as flawless and
like the bottom of a baby channing tatum
got nude on day two of filming for the
lost city a traditional actor's greeting
the poor man had leeches glued to his
butt and sandra bullock's eyes glued to
his privates for an entire two-page
monologue too he dropped everything and
i spoke to it bullock had some extra
comments to say on tatum's butt channing
is so comfortable with himself he knew
was for comedy he wasn't trying to be
serious he worked really hard to make
sure when his rear end turned into frame
that it was perfect i mean i looked i
looked for imperfections it's a hell of
a day too let me just say that number
two sandra bullock's jumpsuit was
stronger than channing tatum the
jumpsuit was intentionally made to be as
uncomfortable as possible but bullock
loved it anyway the jumpsuit is a
character unto itself the thing had to
be designed to endure rivers oceans the
mountainside and channing tatum's head
yes the designers had to keep in mind
the scene where the two climbed the
cliff and tatum had his head between her
legs assisting her to the top bullock
joked it didn't scratch channing's face
which was very important it had to be in
a lot of places and it was just epic the
jumpsuit was so restrictive that it
didn't allow for bullock to drink
liquids or eat a whole lot and the craft
table was just a big tease i'm gonna be
talking about the jumpsuit for the rest
of my life but would i have changed it
hell no number three after spending
weeks filming in the water you'd think
tatum would be sick of it too the day
filming wrapped channing tatum took
sandra bullock for a dip in the water
she wasn't too happy about it but they
ended up hugging it out number four the
far superior title got dropped the
original title for the movie definitely
had much less nuance to it you may
recall in its earlier days when it was
called the lost city of d which was of
course a double entendre while also
playing on the book turned movie that
tom holland starred in called the lost
city of zee which premiered in 2016
tatum begrudged the change saying i
wished they wouldn't have dropped the d
you never drop the d
number five shooting a movie in a
beautiful jungle is the definition of
escapism we're pretty sure
this movie was a form of escapism for
sandra bullock at least coming out of
two years of the pandemic it's been a
long time since i've laughed
following this movie bullock is taking a
break from acting to spend some time
with her family number six one of the
greatest cameos of 2022 is most likely
going to be brad pitts unless marvel
pulls another fast one on us it was
orchestrated in the most interesting of
ways he and sandra bullock share a hair
stylist bullock agreed to be in pitt's
movie bullet train in exchange for him
appearing in the lost city we need to
find ourselves better hair stylists
bullock said he just came in and he tore
it up he's really funny pit's role only
took four days to film oh and he had
tatum fanboying too number seven some
tropes are too good to let go of the
lost city is turning certain tropes on
their head including making bullock's
character have more real-world
experience than her counterpart not all
tropes are destroyed though as they
manage to take the inappropriate jungle
clothing trope even further than it's
ever gone bullock loves it though
stating that's what's so much fun about
it you can take old setups and easily
make them new and the fun thing about
the male female narrative is that now we
can turn it on its ear because it's no
longer this is the woman's role this is
the man's role you can mess with all of
that and create a whole new dynamic and
that's sort of what we did number eight
we bet tatum will put wigs in his
contracts from now on i've never had
long hair in my life i just can't do it
once channing tatum put that wig on he
became a whole other person completely
embodying the hair your personality
changed when you walked out perhaps it
was a mind control cap number nine we're
only a lot jealous about the shooting
location for this one filming happened
in the beautiful dominican republic the
movie started filming in may and wrapped
in august yeah we got to hang out there
for three months so it was pretty great
daniel radcliffe tried to not rub it in
his friends faces too much given kovid
restrictions back in england were still
pretty tight then
number 10 radcliffe was too easily
swayed they didn't even need to mention
brad pitt to convince him to take the
role he was easily sold on being part of
the film knowing he would get to be a
villain across from sandra bullock and
channing tatum sandra i grew up watching
her movies and i grew up as a fan of her
it's no wonder why radcliffe wanted to
work with them he speaks highly of their
work and on-screen chemistry they would
both be i think very hard people to not
have chemistry with so for radcliffe to
be working with her was surreal and
intimidating but that sensation went
away quickly the lost city is the movie
the world has been hungry for ever since
the pandemic began honestly it looks
like a blast no overthinking just
laughing and how about that title change
huh which do you think was better the
lost city of d or the lost city let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things